[Musik]
im kampf gegen das corona virus steht
martin bühler im kanton graubünden an
vorderster front
jede der vielen situation sie sagen sind
knapp drei jungs so genug
juni in mainz kleines studio und so
grund ist aber nicht wie street hatte
mit der frau war geteilt sondern
vielmehr wichtig ist dass sie jetzt oder
unterwegs ist wo viel kontakt und
verhütung ist das nicht im familien
tragen wie zieht ein krisen chef im
hintergrund der pandemie die fäden wenn
es verdachtsfall möchte der heilbar
welche hindernisse stellen sich ihm in
den weg
gott ist das rose und wie sehen seine
tage im ausnahmezustand aus handtaschen
priorisieren
eine chronologie über zwei monate in
zeiten von corona
freitag 6 märz zivilschutzanlage meyers
boden in chur martin bühler chef des
kantonalen führungsstabs in gruppen kurz
vor beginn des lage rapports ziel ist
nicht dass man da zu diskutieren sondern
dass man ruf nehmen was die kriterien
entscheiden war diskutiert sie ist eine
frau wie sie sonst von hand neu in
dieser größenordnung im kanton viele
involvierte aus allen ämtern haben sich
karl erneute versammelt zudem fünf tage
weg sei es in der schweiz momentan gibt
es 80 bestätigt gefällt bestätigt durch
referenzlabor in genf als er den ersten
todesfall im kanton waadt was sie mehr
die evangelische gelage entwicklung in
einigen tagen kunstsommer starken
anstieg an erkrankungen aufgrund von
lokaler überträger in einige wochen
kunst möglich verwies im
gesundheitswesen zu personeller und
infrastruktureller engpass für unsere
ich in der bevölkerung steigt wieder
also schmidt direkte auswirkung
hoffentlich als rechner und durch
hamsterkäufe wird vorübergehend
zulieferer in beeskow in der jeder
tropfen die maßnahme ihr könnt sie
lassen nur zu den öko und das ist
einerseits mehr überblick über co
darum wenn man das lagezentrum ihr
richter was treffen zu einer gemeinde
dafür maßnahmen geht frage den schulen
ist es untersagt ausflüge oder reisen
ins ausland durchzuführen
das gilt das für die recht als
verdächtig gilt nicht aber was heißt es
sind die konsequent wenn wir in russland
geschäftlich wenn wir ins ausland wir
empfehlen
wochenends mailand jetzt günstig ist und
alle dummen sind es mitte mai nicht mehr
weil eine empfehlung ab die ausreise
kieselstein kicker weder vom bund noch
vor anderen daran dass die schäden sind
persönliche individuelle entscheidung
will ich in coronel angeschoben alle wii
sowie bringen mental der schätzfrage
voran schön wenn man da die mentale
bereitschaft stufen hemd und täter
sitzen und mitdenken was man zum gurt
tragen den himmel extrem viel erreicht s
bahnen sich außergewöhnliche zeiten an
vorbereitungen laufen den arbeitsalltag
auf den kopf zu stellen
rallye die hersteller sind dieser beruf
13 an ihrem bcm konzept schafft das
heißt skodas einzel mitarbeiterin der eu
schaffe die zusammenhang mit krone
natürlich wenn sie niemand offen ins
büro
cool messe vielmehr wird das glaube ich
eher voraus setzung wo jetzt wirklich
muss sicher gestellt sie dass alle
dienststellen wohin also ganz hat
verdankt das ist genau jetzt das was man
braucht und dass man auf der falschen
die planiger machen seit mitte februar
ist martin bühler als krisen chef im
einsatz
blenden wir zurück dienstag 25
februar drei wochen bevor die wirtschaft
durch den bundesrat praktisch
stillgelegt wird begleiten wir martin
bühler zum ersten mal
der 44 jährige studierte
politikwissenschaft staats und
völkerrecht in der armee ist der
oberstleutnant im generalstab des
kommandos für spezialkräfte
er war militärbeobachter in israel und
im balkan sei 2016 ist der leiter des
amtes für militär und zivilschutz
jetzt ist er mehr gefordert denn je dank
eines pandemie plans sind die bündner
aber gut vorbereitet also doch selbst er
ich glaube der schutzmaske wir als
medizinische maske und mir händ
möglichkeit der berufung bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz
wirklich für notfall- und viel höhere
priorisierung mit höherer qualität jetzt
stellen und die haben sofort gebrauch
gemacht für die möglichkeit die sind
auch das sind ja genau
und das sind teilnehmerinnen offen
darauf vorbereitet das sind der
schutzmasken vor einer 500 musikstück
und 50 uhr zwei bis drei stunden denkt
freitag 28 februar bundesrat aller börse
tritt vor die medien
zu diesem zeitpunkt haben sich in der
schweiz laut bundesamt für gesundheit
bmg 29 menschen mit dem corona virus
angesteckt und deswegen ihre heute
entschieden in der sitzung von heute
morgen dass die situation in der schweiz
ist als besondere lage einzustufen
gemäss dem im gesetz artikel 6 und wenn
wir auch entschieden dass
großveranstaltungen mit mehr als 1000
personen sind zu verbieten und diese
verordnung ist in kraft seit heute
morgen 10 hoch der krisen chef und sein
stab reagieren umgehend auf die neue
situation zum beispiel hier will das
team beantwortet schriftlich eingehende
fragen aus der bevölkerung
die us-futures eric mindich sind wir
aber dem allgemein heimat positive art
und liezen froh dass man ihnen als wäre
sie mit dem selektiven meine analysen
als besucher und wir sind ein
zivilschützer sind in kontakt mit
menschen die in verdacht stehen sich mit
dem corona virus angesteckt zu haben
im bündnerland gibt es bisher zwei
bestätigte fälle
trotz vorhandenem pandemie plan läuft
noch nicht alles reibungslos so gibt es
beispielsweise keine gemeinsame
kommunikationsstelle für alle
departemente müller will das ändern
doch nicht alle kaderleute sind darauf
vorbereitet
sie haben mühe kompetenzen abzugeben
wichtig ist das lied wofür die frage
antworten kriegen ohne dass man suche
das ist ziel von ganze
kommunikationsstelle awo ab magic life
gott dessen wir mal wissen wo ist
problem und was will man erreiche habe
zu sehr gespürt aber der so
100-prozentig noch nicht glauben ich
kann dir den ablauf jetzt auch nicht
vorbei
es braucht ein bisschen hofnarr geister
sagt okay jetzt auch aber klar sind und
sagen wir klar sehen wir jetzt in eine
unklare situation probiere möglichstes
synchronisiert systems bauer
ich habe die zeit du ehrlich ich habe
mein wissen noch nicht möchte dass
ähnlich wie in anderen erwarte die nato
oder erwartet jens kühl kann
aber das jetzt gehört wissen man geht
der verführung frauentreff als die
einstellung hat am ende als
regierungsrot wir haben genug nach zwei
wochen mit dem afa teams schaffen oder
wenn man sieben teams anne will dass
jetzt alle der parlament und alle hoch
angesiedelte stelle last mittragen
ich kann es mir möglich ist meint dick
und dünn steg zum da sie und somit dem
7000 thema formuliert
insofern sie schmiss angebot
präsentieren verweist historische und in
der ersten phase hilft damit die
verschiedenen bedürfnisse gewählt wird
vielen dank höherem berufen
es war wirklich cool danke es ist ihm
gelungen die leute mit ins boot zu holen
anschließend die dauernd vor ihnen
danach wieder und und machet ramos und
dem aber du herr schneider auch im kopf
wenn man kurz haben wir schon sehr
völlig ja es ist jetzt wie sich
funktioniert die sarstedter halb der
kantine dieser zivilschutzanlage hat
martin bühler anfang märz eine kleine
wohnung bezogen eine frühzeitige
maßnahme zum schutz seiner frau und der
drei kinder
also das ist jetzt das studio und der
grund dass man den charts wo ich
eigentlich
einerseits sieht dass sie will ich viel
unterwegs bin sicher bin dass sie meine
familie nicht irgendwie auch steckt wenn
das könnte passieren wenn die frauschaft
gelocktes gleichzeitig führt und wenn
man einfach sehe ich dass etwas
funktioniert mein appartement sowie nur
der hayek 7 gerade in der ersten phase
dass sie zum teil auch der heimische
verbreiteten also ruhe und ordnung
gefunden eigentlich das gut wenn hier
mal wie oft aber konzentrieren und
möchte in späteren zeitpunkt wieder mehr
familienarbeit hat ja persönliche
gestank noch ihren nicht viel
persönlicher als techno
wir haben weder krafttraining machen und
haben wir zwei händler mit
training ist seht ihr profil ist der
harz fahrer und der trage und zitate und
die ruhe und die und so persönlich wie
es auch was familien aber an die
zeichnung über kopf von ihnen töchter
geschrieben zusammen heute verzeichnet
sie wird papa ich vermisse dich und ich
hoffe dass der korona virus bald wieder
weg ist und du wieder zurückkommen
kannst ich habe ich sehr sehr gerne
deine maria das ist glaub sie sonntag
achter märz schloss altenstein müller
hat den krisenstab einberufen
mittlerweile gibt es in der schweiz
gemäss angaben des biaggi 428 corona
fälle zwei menschen mit kobe 19 sind
gestorben
in norditalien ist die situation außer
kontrolle
positiv der start der filmmusik sind
zwei die musik sie warum
aufgrund einer zweiten siegs über 110
570 sei es wenn da sie trifft das in
hoffnungslosen vision ist die kein grund
warum das bei uns nicht passieren wir
kriegen immer von oben schafft bringen
dass ich morgen eventuell planung
komplexer systems müsse wieder ein
bisschen was ich das wieder vorlaufzeit
bis ein raum der spitze getrennt und was
1.1 mit david leans güter beschlossen
hatte und es sind zwischen 500.000 und
je nach geplant
jetzt stellen sie eigentlich vorbereitet
übrigens im sport und jetzt müssen wir
ja wer
sage besuchen betreuung und sanitäter
und zivilschutz ist so ein erste wahl
annehmen und nach vielen dank donnerstag
märz unterwegs ins misox das tal in
südbünden grenzt an den kanton tessin
dort wurden schulen kinos sportzentren
und nachtclubs geschlossen mit 180
infizierten und 2 todesfällen liegt die
sonnenstube der schweiz weit über dem
kantonalen schnitt sind so führt das
glück hat sich sehr bewegend und
frequenz geht in socs und dadurch ein
starkes potenzial dass ein röhrchen
potenzial für den ausstieg in südbünden
wollen viele gemeinden die verschärften
maßnahmen des tessins übernehmen
in den restlichen gebieten doppelten
suite mann vorläufig keine strengeren
vorschriften müller trifft sich in
rovereto mit den präsidenten der
gemeinden des mi6 situation auf der
anderen seite der berge ist die
situation anders als hier
ich bin hier um eine gemeinsame lösung
zu finden man muss nicht darüber
diskutieren was zu tun sei ich will
dieselben verschärfte maßnahmen wie das
tessin wenn die die tessiner maßnahmen
einführen gibt es ein chaos
ich mache was ich will auch zum wohle
meiner gemeinde die anderen können für
sich selber schauen finito die situation
ist angespannt
müller versucht zu vermitteln
einer seiner mitarbeiter könne die misox
unterstützen er werde helfen einen
gemeinsamen führungsstab aufzubauen
schlussendlich akzeptieren die
anwesenden die idee des krisen chefs
nach dem einschalten usa sind an den
europäischen börsen die kurse erneut
angebrochen
wenn man zu den aktionen börsendaten die
einigkeit aber es ist nicht gelungen
gemeinsame lösung für die umsetzung zu
finden und das macht es gut in der faser
jetzt kommunikativ schwierig die
ausstattung für sie weil man da merkt
muster viel diskutiert und bezüglich
sort leichter als das nur aus strengen
ich bin einfach jetzt eigentlich wusste
sie zu groß um einen der schwierigen
situation die mainz präsidentin und
mainz präsident druck und war hat nach
der bevölkerung aufgaben
jetzt.de emotionen aber nicht weil die
gemeinde mesocco am südfuss des san
bernardino martin bühler will hier
zivilschützer besuchen die in einem
altersheim dienst leisten
außerdem maßnahmen gesetzt besuchsverbot
das besuchsverbot gilt aber für alle
selbst für den krisen chef
es bleibt ihm nichts anderes übrig als
eine schriftliche mitteilung an seine
zivilschützer zu hinterlassen und sie
haben nur gewisse organisiert ist gott
ich habe mir hat heute vorrang hat den
helios sowie rück sich das klima
verändert so christian gratzer tantow
sonderregeln zwischen den kantonen und
dispute zwischen gemeinden wie im misox
drei tage später verordnet der bundesrat
eine maßnahme die für alle gilt eine
weitgehende stilllegung der wirtschaft
montag sechzehnter märz und es rätin
simonetta sommaruga gibt die
hiobsbotschaft bekannt außer
lebensmittelgeschäften apotheken und
drogerien müssen alle verkaufsläden
schließen
der bundesrat hat heute entschieden die
situation als außerordentliche lage zu
erklären
die regelung gilt ab mitternacht und
dauert vorerst bis 19 april
damit haben wir in der ganzen schweiz
einheitliche regeln
jetzt muss ein ruck durchs land gehen
mittwoch 18
märz unterwegs ins engadin die schweiz
verzeichnet an diesem tag laut bhg über
6.000 infizierte 50 menschen starben
bisher am corona virus seit einem monat
kämpft der krisen chef gegen die sich
ausbreitende pandemie
ein konflikt aufgeheizt dass man ein
einigermaßen nützlicher frist wieder
abzuschaffen kommt ankunft in der
truppenunterkunft in stans martin bühler
trifft sich mit offizieren der armee
sein gesuch ans militär um unterstützung
war erfolgreich was mich interessiert
ist was er eigentlich als
leistungsprofil sind was ihr machen da
was er vor allem mitmachen
also dann haben wir mal das spitzenamt
des spitals oder alt da spielt also tat
ich es bildet grundpflege instabile
situation sieht stelle aber dann haben
sie transportzug patiententransport
täter mehr selbständig stabile patienten
transportieren
die trendfarbe vaduz ein oder zwei
begleiter stehen sagt sie das noch
also mehrere fahrer durch kiefer und ein
bis zwei begleiter sohn und die sie
liebt friends schichtbetrieb schaffen
mehr zahlen ein spital nicht fleckig und
für die ganze kontron wenn jens
entschädigung sprechen wird das wäre
1000 später durchgeführt
mit dem leistungskatalog der armee geht
es dann zum nächsten treffen
bühler hat spital direktoren und
kaderleute des grenzwachtkorps es
eingeladen
das ist so das leistungsspektrum vor dem
testament vom 5 darüber verhandle soll
marco welzel makro und war krieg fast
stabil der patient den wir zu ihnen
schwierige die beteiligung bitte
grundpflege jetzt im moment
ausschließlich mein letzter stand der
dinge hallo ich brauche ich sie nicht im
moment aber das reicht jedoch ein
anderer gerade jetzt in den etwas
politisch und populistischen länder wie
österreich oder anderen die einfach
jetzt zu dem schritt kommen und sagen
italienische staatsbürger müssen da
bleiben und ich sehe das nicht so
unrealistisch also muss ich sagen gibt
es von der woche nichts hat und wenn das
eintritt dann habe ich schlagartig dann
bräuchten wir wahrscheinlich jeder ein
eigenes bataillon im spital weiter zu
führen wo wir 154 blütenmeer und 17.15
uhr vorstellen dass ich einfach mehr als
50 prozent
und wenn das natürlich in der nacht dazu
ort macht wird er sich natürlich einfach
gerüchte dass größtes problem lösen das
ist gewiss nicht
der armee einsatz in den spitälern ist
also momentan nicht notwendig sorgen
machen den spital direktorin aber die
grenzübergänge die nachts geschlossen
werden sollen unser personal wird in
zukunft extrem belastet und ausgelastet
und jetzt verstehe ich nicht wir müssen
24 stunden dienste überbelastungen
fahren ich verstehe immer noch nicht
warum die grenze nachts nicht besetzt
sein kann das ist mein problem dass sie
zu ist es für mich überhaupt kein
problem aber es kann doch nicht sein
dass man sagt wir sollen mit unseren
mitarbeitern hochfahren die sollen immer
noch italien heim fahren sollen
das haben machen unsere mitarbeiter sie
werden dafür bereit aber es kann auch
nicht sein wenn er in so einer situation
er sagt es gibt andere polizei militär
zivilschutz militärs aktiviert worden
und warum das habe ich nicht ganz
verstanden warum wird die grenze nachts
nicht besetzt
das grenzwacht ihn dürfen wir zwar
firmen nicht jedoch ihren originalton
verwenden
man habe zu wenig leute um alle
übergänge rund um die uhr zu besetzen
sagt die kader frau der grenzwacht dann
finden die anwesenden eine lösung die
zoll übergänge werden durch zusätzliches
wachpersonal auch nachts besetzt damit
kann das spitalpersonal aus italien nach
der arbeit heimkehren
es muss grenzwache polizei oder
zivilschutz dabei sein
und das machen wir so und dann suchen
wir diesen diesen plan aufzustellen
wieder ist ein problem vom tisch
bühler trifft täglich viele menschen die
gefahr ist groß dass er selber mit dem
corona virus angesteckt wird ein paar
tage danach aus sicherheitsgründen
findet das wiedersehen per video
konferenz statt was ich mit ihrem team
das so donnerstag 16 april nach vier
wochen stillstand bisher starben laut
angaben des brg über 1100 menschen am
corona virus aber es gibt auch gute
nachrichten die ausbreitung des corona
virus wurde gebremst und unsere spitäler
sind zurzeit nicht überlastet das ist
eine gute nachricht die folgt gleich
eine weitere gute nachricht nun können
wir erste lockerungen vorsehen
samstag 18 april noch immer ist die
zivilschutzanlage bei chur der wohnsitz
des krisen chefs seien am corona virus
erkrankt zivilschützer ist wieder gesund
martin bühler blieb es die ganze zeit
hindurch in den ersten zwei monaten des
ausnahmezustandes habe er die
zusammenarbeit mit allen beteiligten
geschätzt doch ganz zufrieden ist er
nicht
die war eine rolle besetzt ist das nicht
der fall und wünsche japan und über den
staubsauger sondern gemacht hat aber ein
altbekannter die kommunikation
nach innen wie nach außen gerade will
muss soviel akteure hand so viele
unterschiedliche wahrnehmung nämlich
schon als einige der größten erfolge mit
und wie man das wenn du organisiert auch
immer noch ufer schaffen müsste sich
schon konkret wenn sie wieder zurück zu
der familie und das ist nicht einmal
jetzt nowak der krankheit sonderfaktor
intensität von der albert wo ich mich
entschied anders sieht es da wir hören
auf das konzentrieren die weiße setzen
und ich freue mich ruft und genau
gespannt auf der verlauf für den
elektriker und wenn das gut auf den
winter in dem monat wieder abgeschafft